dann sage ich herzlich Willkommen hier
bei uns in der Stadtbibliothek ich
begrüße ganz herzlich zu unserem
philosophischen Nacht naja jetzt noch
eher abends Kaffee schauen wir mal ob
wir sie ein bisschen die Nacht
hineinkommen hier bei uns im Rahmen der
Themenwelt wohnen mein Name ist Eva weg
ich bin hier von der Stadtbibliothek und
ich
würde seit Sätze ganz ganz so Themenwelt
sagen dass sie so ein bisschen einen
Eindruck kriegen warum die Bibliothek
sich plötzlich mit sowas wie
philosophischen machtkaffee
auseinandersetzt die Themenwelten sind
relativ neues Format seit Ende letzten
Jahres und wo wir dreimal im Jahr
versuchen ein bestimmtes Thema in
unterschiedlichen Kontexten ja erlebbar
erfahrbar zu machen immer mit einer
kleinen Ausstellung das ist ein separade
quasi mitten drinnen in den Modellen in
den Bauteilen aus dem 3D Drucker neben
Maulwurfshügeln und Vogelnestern weil
wir uns im Herbst mit dem Thema Wohnen
beschäftigen
wie wohnen wir wo wohnen wir
hinter mir sehen Sie vielleicht unsere
papp-burg das Iglo muss man heute ein
bisschen aus dem Weg nehmen und wir
wollen uns ein bisschen mit den Fragen
beschäftigen eben wie wohnen die wir
haben wir gewohnt und wir werden wir
zukünftig wohnen oder vielleicht auch
wie müssen wir zukünftig wohnen wenn der
Platz nicht mehr reicht wenn ganze
Landstriche vielleicht ungewohnbar
werden wenn wir riesige Migrationsströme
über diesen Planeten bekommen und wir
möchten uns heute Abend überlegen könnte
das meta-works könnt ihr die virtuelle
Realität denn eine Wohnform der Zukunft
sein was passiert denn mit dem Menschen
wenn er sich quasi aus der realen Welt
in die virtuelle Realität
begibt und mit all den Fragen möchten
wir uns heute beschäftigen
freue mich sehr zwei ja Experten für
dieses Thema hier zum haben zum einen
gehört Noller deutscher Philosoph als
der sich ganz viel mit der Philosophie
der Digitalität ist schon beschäftigt
hat und wo man Backwelt
et der
deutsche Gamification Experte und
spieletheorie Experte in Deutschland mit
dem ich tatsächlich schon ganz ganz
viele Arten über ganz viele andere
Sachen diskutiert habe und ich freue
mich voll tatsächlich dass wir über das
meterwars als Wohnform sprechen ja
wir haben ja gesagt wir möchten gerne
deswegen stehen auch das Kind hier und
hinter uns dann auch mit so ein zwei
Beispielen anfangen und das ganze so ein
bisschen aufzuhören aufzuhängen ich habe
aber tatsächlich heute Vorbereitung auf
den Arm nicht die ganze Zeit gefragt und
ich glaube es ist so die erste Frage wo
ich schon mal ja ein erstes Statement
von euch und müssen immer so übers und
die virtuelle Realität reden was ist das
eigentlich ja was ist für dich das
metavers wie virtuelle Realität wir
hatten Vorgespräche auch so ein bisschen
so der Unterschied zwischen Sein und
schreien
genau dann möchte ich einfach mal auf
diesen Slogan hier zu sprechen kommen in
einem der neuesten spiegelausgaben
findet man die Werbung von Meta und
unten steht das wetterversumer virtuell
sein aber es wird ein realen Einfluss
haben und das hat mir zu denken gegeben
und zwar deswegen bei der steht ist man
nur virtuell sein aber es hat
einen Details David die Virtualität und
die Realität des virtuellen wird
100 gegenübergesetzt zwar als Art
Widerspruch und ich glaube das ist
gerade falsch weil ich glaube Meta hat
hier selbst
ganz allgemein versteht und der
virtuelle Realität jetzt nicht nur das
was Meta Facebook und so weiter machen
virtuelle Realität ist ein ganz
alltägliches Phänomen das kennt jeder
von uns Banknoten Banknoten sind
virtuelle Realitäten warum weil der Wert
den ist Papierstück hat nicht in den
Papierstück bestehen sondern in einer
ganz komplexen Hintern subjektiven
Gemeinschaft da gehört eine Zentralbank
dazu der gehören Übereinkünfte soziale
ganz komplexe Phänomene dazu und das ist
das typische Beispiel von Virtual
Realität also wenn du jetzt mich fragst
was reicht in der Luft und so sage ich
das kannten wir alles schon auch vor
Facebook Meter virtuelle Realität ist
ein uraltes menschlich kulturelles
Phänomen das sei jetzt mal ganz kurz
dazu
naja wie du schon gesagt hast virtuelle
virtuelle Realität also für mich ist das
mal Zeit Zeit dass ich mich ausmacht
virtuelles ne also wir haben irgendwann
mal festgelegt was eine Stunde eine
Minute ein Tag ein Monat und haben so
quasi unser Leben eingeteilt ist
eigentlich auch was total virtuelles na
also wie du schon sagst eigentlich was
was schon ganz lange da ist ja Roman
was ist für dich das methabe
wenn man das wirklich so genau damit
virtuellen stimmt dass er aber um dabei
für die für die Einfachheit
sind es für also virtuell und Meter
wirst sind zwei unterschiedliche Dinger
es virtuelle klar nehmen wir mal das
ganz plastische ich kann etwas digital
herstellen ich kann irgendwie sowas
intantines erschaffen meistens natürlich
mit der Technologie der digitalen
Technologien hergesetzt muss auch nicht
sein aber das ist nun mal den Punkt
und dann kann ich da reingehen egal ob
es 2ds 3DS ja das hat auch ein bisschen
was damit zu tun wie ich selber
eintauche also wenn man komplett immer
sieht und gewisse 2d-welten eintaucht
dann ist das was du als wenn man in
einer 3D Welt und was ist auch dazu das
Meta was selber muss ja nicht virtuell
sein also weil du das beides genannt
hast ja alles klar also die Medien
verbinden es nur noch damit dass das
Buch
hier wodurch das Metern was das erste
mal gekonnt wurde Name wie ist das Buch
noch mal
wir hatten schon drüber gesprochen
finden
wurde der Begriff Metern was genannt und
auch da wurde er schon mit einer Brille
verbunden also von daher und auch
natürlich klar Meta selber verbindet das
alles damit von einer glauben immer
gleiches was aber für mich persönlich
ehrlich gesagt ist das metabors eine
Möglichkeit um Leute scheinbar
zusammenzubringen wir haben wirklich das
Gefühl die sind zusammen
egal wo Sie sitzen ne also das heißt
nicht wenn du zum Beispiel auf der
Webseite bist du bist zusammen beim
Shoppen irgendwie dann ist jeder Sache
wir sind tausende zugleich auf derselben
Webseite die kriegen wird das ist das
hat damit nichts zu tun aber das
metadresse meines nicht das bringt die
Leute zusammen und die virtuelle
Technologie ist natürlich Signale dafür
wenn
sie bringen scheinbar Versand gebracht
es hat auch was mit Illusion zu tun als
denkt man häufig mehr wird nur virtuell
hier wieder nur häufig wird
Emission verbunden damit
wirtschaftlichen Schein und da möchte
ich eine Lanze brechen für den Realismus
also für das reale des virtuellen ich
glaube wenn wir im Metaversum was auch
immer das jetzt ist was du jetzt zum
Beispiel gebracht hast wenn wir mit
anderen Menschen auf der Welt auf ganz
anderen Kontinenten interagieren durch
das Internet oder durch dieses Metall
wir sind dann sind wir scheinbar mit den
zusammen sondern da ist eine Realität
damit verbunden wir sind zwar nicht
physisch körperlich mit denselben Raum
obwohl uns das
illusionär im ersiv
sogar aber wir machen
was tatsächlich real ist und das finde
ich das spannend ja also immer die Frage
was ist jetzt im Metallversion nur
Illusion scheint und was ist tatsächlich
wirklich und nicht nur virtuell darauf
möchte ich als Philosoph besonders
hinweisen was ist denn jetzt wirklich
real im Metall also wirklich im Kopf
was hat die Kräfte wo würden wir sagen
das ist nicht nur eine Simulation ist es
wirklich tatsächlich relevant vielleicht
auch juristisch moralische tun ja auch
Dinge wenn perversum und Ende sitzt nur
Spielereien und Illusion sind dann
können wir tun was wir wollen aber ich
glaube so einfach in dieses nicht ich
glaube wir können auch tatsächlich die
metavers wie Dinge tun die unor
den Frage eben da ist es jetzt wirklich
real oder es ist nur eine Spiel ja okay
wie auch immer mit dem rechtlichen
stimmt richtig okay was ich meinte mit
Schreiben als physisch nicht alle
zusammen da stimme ich Dir teil und das
stimmt also ich sehe selber nutzen bei
uns die virtuelle Realität zum arbeiten
also wir haben ein Team auf der ganzen
Welt verteilt wir treffen uns
wöchentlich weil gewissen Meetings und
haben es am Anfang ihres Spiel genommen
die VR Brille aufgesetzt und dann
irgendwie gemerkt okay irgendwas ist
anders also auf jeden Fall im Gegensatz
zu Zoom oder Teams oder wie auch immer
und war schon stimmt klar besetzt die
Brille auf in den ersten zwei Minuten
sagst du auch wieder weil er eben wieder
eine Woche lang nicht drin warst ach ja
ist natürlich alles noch irgendwie wird
also irgendwie sieht halt irgendwie
anders aus lustig sonst setz ich mich
heute mal hin wie auch immer wenn du
dann mal drin bist beim Arbeiten also
wenn du dann das um dich herum vergisst
in dieser Brille weil du dich auf dein
Thema konzentrierst weil du anfängst zu
diskutieren
dann merkst du schon dass diese ganzen
Sachen real passieren in deinem Gehirn
also ist auch wirklich so das ist
ungelogen ich weiß nicht ob man das auch
sagen soll wenn manche denken dann
vielleicht oh Gott der arme Kerl aber
wenn ich nach zwei Stunden Meeting mit
unseren Leuten
die Brille abnehmen also mehr als zwei
Stunden kriegen wir nicht hin also das
ist dann wenn man also beim Arbeiten
wenn man sich rückverhältnis 2 Stunden
aber nach zwei Stunden das abnimmst und
du hast dir so ein virtuellen Raum
geschaffen zum arbeiten wo zum Beispiel
auf einer Terrasse am Meer sitzt
ungelogen du hast das Gefühl ich war
fast am Meer also du kommst nach Hause
und sagst so gefühlt Leute deine Frau
Stress mit den Kindern gehabt und
irgendwie in ihrem Büro gesessen und tut
fühlst dich was zu Schuldigen irgendwie
mache ich ja mehr gefühlt also von daher
du bist natürlich es ist physisch nicht
real aber im Kopf hat es natürlich ein
bisschen Einfluss und das zeigt Wirkung
das ist glaube ich die richtige Punkt es
zeigt Wirkung du hast dich praktisch was
das beschrieben hast würde ich jetzt
eine virtuelle Entspannung
virtuelle ein virtuelle Urlaub oder
sowas ne virtuell Material und du warst
nicht wirklich an einem
mies war ein simuliertes mehr aber du
bist immer sie weil du bist der wirklich
eingetaucht und es hat den Zweck also
den realen Zweck verfolgt dass du am
Ende entspannt hast und da kann man dann
glaube ich nicht mehr nur davon sprechen
dass eine große Spielerei sondern da
kommt tatsächlich eine Realität in den
Alltag das ist vielleicht auch Punkt und
nochmal zurückzukommen auf die Frage was
ist das metallversum ich glaube es ist
eben
ein Phänomen was immer mehr in unserem
Alltag sich bemerkbar macht auch bei der
Arbeit du kannst davon
das ist nicht nur in Anführungsstrichen
der Spielereien den nutzen unsere
Spielerei es wird ja häufig Gamification
oder im Sinne der große Spielerei
gesehen da würde ich überhaupt nicht
zustimmen sondern sitzen Phänomen was
wir immer mehr in
unseren Anweisung auch in konomischen
möglich sinnvoll einsetzen
vollkommen also bei uns in Sachen
schneller geworden wir werden mal rein
Geld durch das Ding eher als er also das
wird weniger die Leute am Wochenende
also wir haben eher dass er als bei Zoom
das Gefühl gehabt beim magenselben Raum
sondern bei so meckern sind alle klar
aber irgendwie
muss man sich mal wieder sehen warum
nicht drüber reden ist so aber so eine
Hybrid sein aber das ist mir jetzt
tatsächlich total spannend weil also
weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht aber
tatsächlich wir hoffen der Bibliothek
natürlich seid Corona ich würde sagen 50
Prozent der Meetings nach wie vor immer
noch über Teams oder Zoo und ich glaube
ja irgendwas ist ja den Begriff des
immersiven eingebracht hat also für mich
schon auch trotzdem noch mal die
spannende Frage und wenn wir nachher
irgendwann auch noch mal den Bogen zum
zum Wohnen spannend was ja dann noch
viel mehr ist als nur arbeiten klar
mittlerweile arbeiten auch viele daheim
in der Wohnung im Haus
macht es trotzdem Unterschied ob ich
dann doch die Brille auf habe oder
einfach nur vom Rechner in Zoom Meeting
sehe weil also ich kann jetzt so aus
meiner ganz persönlichen Erfahrung mehr
dann sitzt du in deinem Büro und bist in
einem MS Teams Meeting oder Zoom Meeting
und es hat ja nichts inversives also du
hörst trotzdem noch dein Telefon
klingeln und jemand an die Tür klopft
und irgendwie gehörst du trotzdem das
klingt wenn dann noch eine E-Mail
reinkommt und es ist ja dann trotzdem
auch viel Ablenkung also für mich
tatsächlich nochmal die Frage ob wir
schauen uns gleich nachher noch mal
Trader tatsächlich von dem Film an wo
das noch mal deutlicher wird dieses
dieser immersive Charakter also braucht
der Mensch dann trotzdem
noch die Technik im Sinne von einer VR
Brille oder vielleicht irgendwann eines
Ganzkörperanzug ist indem wir
reinschlüpfen damit wir wirklich dieses
immersives so ganz krass haben du
schützt nur im Kopf ja meine Oma hat es
jeden Tag in den Garten oder oder also
immer sieht ist ja eine Frage also drei
psychologisches exmassiven ermöglichen
Zustand des Gehirns wo es alles andere
ausblendet und sie komplett auf eine
Sache fokussiert das ist genau jeder
kennt in der von uns wenn du irgendwas
machen und haben das Gefühl wir haben
Zeit einen Raum vergessen also oh das
war eine super Stunde guckst du scheiße
von vier ja das hat er lebt jeder von
uns in toll das ist immer so und das
kannst du das hat damit hat jetzt die
Technik erstmal gar nichts zu tun ja
sie macht es vielleicht ab und zu
einfach also im Großraumbüro in massiv
zu arbeiten ist super schwer da kann ich
für VR Brille helfen weil sie natürlich
mir das leichter macht alles andere
auszublenden aber ich im Gegenteil wir
haben ja Immersion der Menschen erlebt
immer so und seitdem dann Spezies gibt
war deine Oma dann auch in der
virtuellen Realität Fragezeichen
im Garten total immersiv vielleicht
total in ihrer Gedankenwelt versunken
[Musik]
ja also ich denke man muss hier immer
ein bisschen
Loser
Simulator virtuell die Oma im Garten die
hatte jetzt keinen Simulation aber sie
haben die einheitliche Erfahrung das
heißt du glaube ich jetzt mit der gemein
sie hat den ganz klaren Fokus auch was
du meinst mit den verschiedenen
Bildschirmen oder zoomen und da ist auch
ein Handy das ist deswegen keine
einheitliche
also ich würde jetzt mehr Dimension so
bestimmen wie der virtuelle Realität das
ist ein kohärentem einheitlicher Raum
ist die wird gerne mit dem Raumbegriff
noch ein bisschen operieren es geht Dir
ja auch irgendwo wohnen also Räume
müssen ein geschlossenes System
darstellen wo alles seinen richtigen Ort
hat und wo nicht irgendwie eine Lücke
klafft oder ein Fenster offen ist sag
mal wo so ein frischer Wind reinkommt
und nicht irgendwie irritiert so können
wir uns glaube auch die metavias um
annähern das muss ein Raum sein
homogener Raum der in sich klar defin
also alles seinen festen Platz hat und
nicht Objekte plötzlich weg sind ganz
willkürlich sprich es geht auch
Orientierung dieser Begriff scheint mir
fast noch nützlicher zu sein als der der
Inversion bei Immersion häufig auch
natürlich im Kino stattfindet wenn ich
eine riesen Kino Leinwand vor mir habe
dann habe ich tolle Lautsprecher tolle
Effekte dann fühle ich mich
psychologisch irgendwann auch wie ein
Teil dieses Films aber es ist ja nur
Funktionen und worauf es
nie in der reale gehalten nicht nur das
moduliert wird und deswegen würde ich
statt in der Sonne wo ich den Begriff
jetzt
lieber von einem kohärenten Raum spricht
orientierungsraum in dem ich tatsächlich
auch interagieren kann und wo alles
seinen richtigen Ort hat
also ich glaube tatsächlich auch diese
Orientierung
wäre auch irritiert ich komme abends
nach Hause und plötzlich steht das Hofer
bei den Schlafzimmer und ich finde in
der Küche nichts mehr und also der
Begriff ja Orientierung es ist
sicherlich ein ganz ganz wichtiger genau
noch mal
ganz kurz für mich tatsächlich weil ich
mich ja vor allem in der Vorbereitung
auf den Abend damit wird beschäftigt hat
einfach auch noch mal zu Begriffen bei
mir von vom meterwurst reden reden wir
von einem Begriff den tatsächlich auch
bei dir in deiner in deiner Profession
oder wo man auch bei dir als Begriff
gibt oder mein Meta vs wirklich das was
jetzt nicht mehr Facebook sondern der
mieterkonzern sozusagen einfach in den
kommerziellen Rahmen geschaffen hat also
ist es eigentlich richtig wenn wir
prometa wäre so reden oder ist das
eigentlich nur so wie wir zum
Taschenbuch sagen oh nein das was
Facebook erschaffen hat wäre es besser
von virtuellen Realitäten zu sprechen
also einfach nur noch mal von der
Begriff zu Erklärung wir haben heute
darüber gesprochen wir sind der mein
bundesmetaversum gab es einige schon so
2.400 Second Life also Second Life
allerdings virtuell
Ausprägung also es gibt schon viel
länger so ähnliche Phänomene und
Facebook oder Metall springt jetzt eben
wieder drauf auf den Zug nachdem es mal
so ein Tal gab wo es
im ziert hatte alles Phänomen ist
durchaus älter
wird mich jetzt nur was was für Facebook
und Metall gilt wie siehst du also
heutzutage ist es ein Gattungsbegriff es
stehen alles die centraliens genauso
metavers ja fällt da drunter also klar
also wirklich eine redet die meisten
Leute unser Vermietern was reden sagen
ja nicht ich krieg genau von dem was
Meter gebaut hat
das haben die was kann man sehen wenn
man will was das Angebot gemacht mit
ihrer macht sich den Begriff beschnappt
aber ansonsten also normalerweise auch
wenn die Medien davon reden und sowas
die hätten keine Ahnung wenn man sagt ja
weil man das macht Peter nicht das ist
woanders drin also es ist immer ein
ganzes betrifft und vielleicht noch mal
auf deine Frage zurück weil auch das
Wort Metaversum ist natürlich das
Universum steckt natürlich drin das
heißt
es hat wieder Vernetzung der globalen
vernetzt und sowas ist eben schon mit
dem sekund life diesen Online diesen
online-phänomen angedacht gewesen Anfang
der 2000er aber diese Idee die gilt
jetzt nicht nur für Facebook Meta sind
Idee ein virtuellen Handlungsraum ich
bin auch immer ein großer Freund dieses
handlungshaus das heißt wir konsumieren
nicht nur im Internet oder
metaphon was und zwar wirkt ähm diese
Idee eines virtuellen globalen handlungs
so würde ich das Wetter wäre so bestimmt
alles was mich mit anderen Menschen auf
den anderen Seite der Welt vernetzen und
auch interagieren lässt das ist in
meinen teilweise jetzt zum Beispiel
etwas
Universum metaversen wir hatten es
tatsächlich am Vorgespräch schon auch
mal andersrkutiert
das auch mit totalitären Anspruch
ja vielleicht tatsächlich weg vom
politischen Begriff des Brutalitäten
aber hat das tatsächlich auch einen
globalen totalen Anspruch also wir
hatten gleich angesprochen ich kann mich
tatsächlich erinnern zum einen
Schulzeiten war es glaube ich World of
Warcraft das Computerspiel auch mit der
Version was ist
untergarantie für viele meiner
Freundinnen unsere Freunde tatsächlich
dann auch zu einem Wohnort geworden ist
zeitweise also tatsächlich die Frage in
diesem Begriff Metaversum Universum
steckt da tatsächlich auch so ein
totaler Anspruch mit wie seht ihr das
also du hast wie ich finde auf einen
guten das Bett hingewiesen global und
total global ist gut total da wird schon
ein bisschen problematisch geht es
totalitäre vielleicht rein sprich wir
müssen uns immer Fragen sind wir im
Metaversum freiwesen oder werden wir
fremdbestimmen ja das kann man sich so
ohne weiteres sagen aber es ist dann sei
eben ein gutes wetterversum ich als
Philosophen Moralphilosoph ein gutes
oder sinnvolles metallversum wenn ich
frei bestimmen kann wenn ich meine
individuellen Zwecksetzung verfolgen
kann und wenn jeder Mensch auf die
demokratische Weise partizipieren kann
und nicht irgendwelchen Einschränkungen
seines staatlicher oder finanz welche
andere Arme liegt also in diese
Freiheitsrechte die wir hier zum Glück
genießen wenn die auch im Metaversum
realisiert werden können dann haben wir
sehr viel gewonnen wenn wir hingegen
metavversum lose konsumobjekte sind
Datenobjekte von großen Unternehmen und
praktisch nur dazu uns im Wetter wäre
Symptome um kontrolliert und
ausspioniert zu werden was manche sagen
ich bin eigentlich jetzt nicht der
Meinung aber es könnte man sagen dann
geht es ins totalitäre dann kann man
sagen big Brothers watching you big
Brother 2.0 wäre dann das Wetter
da dürfen wir nicht hin wir müssen immer
auch im wetterversum Auto nur
selbstbestimmt sein und unsere würde
muss auch im metaverse noch geachtet
werden
also es ist politische Stimmung
auch sagen wir nehmen missbraucht wird
oder was man den Extremfall nehmen klar
das kann immer passieren logisch aber
ich glaube wir brauchen nicht größere
handmaßstäbe dran setzen will seine
Realität setzen also auch hier haben
dürfen wir gewisse Dinge nicht machen
oder wir dürfen gewisse Dinge machen ich
weiß wenn nicht wohin gehen und da stehe
ich dir jetzt ein Regeln und das
passiert in der virtuellen Welt genauso
was also ich glaube ich ja
und das ist genauso wie der jetzigen
Welt die
Onlinewelt haben also von daher wird es
ausgenutzt werden klar warum weil man es
kann also miteinander machen ja es ist
immer so können wir damit umgehen können
wir damit leben ja glaube ich auch wir
passen immer an wir lernen wie das
funktioniert
niemand ist gezwungen eine gewisse
Applikation auf der PR äh ich meine das
ist ja schon ich meine wie viel 1000
Apps gibt es schon keiner also jeder
kann das Meter über das Betrachten
betreten ohne Meter zu bet und irgendwas
mit dir zu tun zu haben
und wir stehen gerade mal wir sind
gerade bei fünf Minuten in der Technik
wollen Sie darüber reden was in zwei
Jahren ja also von daher ja das ist eine
Antwort auf die Frage eigentlich nicht
sondern wir uns denken aber positiv
gebracht ne also setzen wir dieselben
arschgeber an die wir auch in der
Realität oder im analogen Raum ansetzen
ne wie du gesagt hast okay ist klar ich
darf diese Sachen ich darf diese Sachen
nicht also
der Bibliothek und vergessen darf ich
hier ein Bier trinken die sind in einer
Bibliothek auf die Reise aufmachen na
also ich habe natürlich immer gewisse
Reglements gewisse Konventionen die ich
in den Räumen habe tatsächlich und ich
glaube ja das war noch ein Aspekt von
dir wenn wir von einer digitalen
Müdigkeit oder Unmöglichkeit reden oder
von einer digitalen Aufklärung also du
hast tatsächlich ein sehr berühmten
Vorgänger kann mit reingebracht und ist
das was uns vielleicht tatsächlich noch
fehlt im Jahre 2022 eine digitale
Aufklärung ich denke auf jeden Fall
Aufklärung brauchen wir in jedem
Zeitalter jedes Zeitalter braucht seine
eigene Aufklärung des 19 Jahrhundert
ganz brauchte die aufbewährung bekannt
hat er über Bücher geschrieben und
gesagt habe ich ein Buch so brauche ich
nicht mehr zu denken das Buch sagt mir
doch schon alles ne habe ich einen Arzt
zu bauen wenn ich mir meine Gesundheit
zu kümmern genauso können wir sagen im
habe ich das Internet so brauche ich
vielleicht auch nicht mehr selbst zu
denken ja oder habe ich irgendwie tolle
Simulationen oder invasive Erfahrungen
so brauche ich nicht mehr in die Welt
hinaus zu gehen oder mich selbst
anzustrengen oder was auch immer als ich
glaube wir müssen immer diese neuen
Medien kritisch hinterfragen kritisch
reflektieren aber in meinen Augen eben
nicht so dass wir sie negieren oder
einfach ja Medium kritisch mehr oder
weniger ins Abseits stellt oder auch die
Familien sind wir müssen in meinen Augen
ein Umgang mit diesen neuen Medien
finden der unsere Freiheit vergrößern
und unsere Freiheit wird dann für
größert wenn wir mit diesem neuen Medien
z.B mit der Börsen Dinge machen können
die wir davor nicht tun können die also
zum Beispiel wie du es beschrieben hast
unseren alltagsprozess effizienter
machen ja wo wir plötzlich uns mit
anderen Menschen auf anderen Kontinenten
auf eine ganz neue Art und Weise in
Verbindung setzen können und so auch
aneinander wachsen obwohl wir wollen
nicht physisch getrennt sind das sind
für mich Zeichen dass hier die
Aufklärung stattfindet Aufklärung findet
dann nicht statt oder
digitalmündigkeit tritt dann ein wenn
wir zum Beispiel abhängig werden von den
Medien wenn wir abhängig werden von
Technologie
raten die wissen wie es läuft und ich
weiß es nicht ich bin abhängig von denen
ja also Mündigkeit bedeutet wir müssen
selbst auch irgendwie medienmedien
autonomen umgehen können und wir selbst
lernen und da spielt die Bildung und
Riesenthema wir müssen anfangen mit den
Kindern sich schon an diese neuen Medien
spielerisch zu gewöhnen damit es nichts
mehr fremdes ist und dass man eigenen
Zugang dazu für die Erwachsenen werden
die Kinder müssen das mit uns machen
oder die Kinder heutzutage vielleicht
schon eher die Kinder
Oma sind wir aufgeklärt digital
also ich glaube das ist ein als
Deutscher Gesellschaft nicht nein
glaube ich nicht weil wir dem ganzen ein
bisschen zu also weil wir uns nicht die
Zeit nehmen
Haltung insgesamt ja kommt aus unserer
Geschichte kommt noch raus kommt
manchmal manche Sachen sind gut also
manche Gründe diese Ableitung zu haben
ist gut zum Beispiel der Datenschutz ja
als Beispiel durchaus rationale Gründe
warum man nicht drüber reden das muss
durchaus habe ich selber schon im Leben
bestimmt oder mitgetrieben aber auf der
anderen Seite durch diese Abwehrhaltung
wenn der Technologie kommt die abhängig
ist vom Datenfluss damit umzugehen was
kann man damit machen wie funktioniert
das wie kann ich trotz der Gefahr damit
leben wir begeben uns gar nicht also wir
versuchen sie komplett abzuwehren wie
gesagt die meisten Leute meins aus guten
Gründen ja aber dadurch haben wir
automatisch Probleme mit dieser
Technologie also ich glaube dass wir auf
das andere war gesagt das ist ich meine
dieses Phänomen der ist erstmal ich
glaube wir sind fähig zu sein auf jeden
Fall ja wenn es halt mal zulassen haben
wir nicht sein heißt auch die negativen
Part erleben also ich habe jetzt kleine
Kinder hier keine so oft wie ich will
sagen dass es schlecht wenn du es machst
dann machen sie es nur weil ich es
gesagt hat nicht weil sie verstanden
haben genauso auch die digitale
Mündigkeit kommt nur in die muss
ausprobierst und schaltest und erlebst
und was kann am schlimmsten Fall
passieren und an das schönste ist immer
ich meine du hast gerade mit dem Buch
angewandt Telefon war selber Telefon
wurde verteufelt ja
lauter diese Sachen es gab mal jemanden
der hat gesagt alles übertrieben aber
irgendwie hat gesagt die Menschen denken
immer schlecht ist das was nach ihrer
Geburt passiert
also du wächst damit auf ist gut weil es
schon immer da war das erkennen wir
übrigens bei Software einführen und die
ist schon im Unternehmen und neue
Mitarbeiter kommt rein der sagt mir da
nutze wenn du schon da bist Du die
softwarest und ein neues Software warum
machen wir das moment mal wollen die
nicht mehr also das ist immer das
gleiche hast du eine hast du gewissen
Status Kohle und der wird verändert und
der wird heutzutage immer schneller
verändert falls du Menschen oft schwerer
und ich glaube wir sind zusätzlich noch
eine Kultur weil wir auch das entweder
mit zusammen wir kommen sind das Land
der Dichter und Denker wir nehmen uns da
unserer Zeit genommen Ingenieurs Wissen
Dinge sind genormt physikalische Gesetze
da kommen wir eher sind immer gleich die
ändern sich nicht und jetzt kommt
plötzlich eine Welt in die die
gesetzlich ständig ändern können und wir
kommen damit nicht ganz gut klar aber
wir sind mündig genug
vielleicht ist es was du sagst auch ein
Plädoyer für ein spielerischen Umgang
mit diesen neuen Medien es muss nicht
sofort perfekt passen und was er gesagt
man kann um einen Fehler machen aber
dabei da das richtige draus lernen
Gaming fictation auch mit der neuen
Technologie nicht zu ernst zu nehmen
sondern was auszuwerten ich glaube das
sind positiver Punkt also ich
beschäftige Psychologie ja wie agieren
Menschen im Spiel und wir sagen immer
der Mensch will keine Veränderung dazu
Probleme damit das stimmt nicht so ganz
weil denkbar an euch selbst jeder von
euch der Brettspiel spielt Kartenspiel
Videospiel von mir aus aber auch ein
Hobby hat oder Sport macht und sowas ihr
wollt dass sich das Ding verändert
sobald es sich nicht mehr verändern
würde also bald Level 1 immer Level 1
bleiben sobald in den angenommen gemacht
Modellbau als als Hobby ja das erste
Modell zusammengebaut ihr kauft euch
nicht das erste Mal
wer aber aus Menschenbild Sicht als
bessere über den schneller werden
effizienter werden keine bösen
Überraschungen macht ihr nicht also das
Spannende ist dass der Mensch freiwillig
in den Situationen wo er macht was er
machen darf freiwillig macht der
absichtlich Situationen im spielsport
Hobby die dadurch definiert sind dass
sie erstens sich ständig ändern dass sie
interessant durch die Überraschung sind
die kommt und das sieht auch noch immer
schwerer werden also ich glaube der
Mensch ist das anpassungsfähigste Wesen
was es gibt weshalb der eigentlich gar
keine Angst vor sowas haben müssten
es macht die Rahmenbedingungen der
Kontext aus aber das macht vielleicht
als Versorgung ein bisschen kürzer dazu
was sagen du hast den Spielbegriff ins
Spiel gebracht und Friedrich Schiller
ich heiße Philosoph deutscher Geist des
Begriff sagt der Mensch ist nur da ganz
Menschen wo er spielt ja also auch da
könnte man so ein bisschen an die
Klassik anknüpfen warum nicht auch mit
dem digitalen mit dem virtuellen Spielen
aus spielen kann auch irgendwann
Realität werden da können
aus getestet werden im Spiel können wir
den virtuellen Raum ausloten und schauen
wo sind die Grenzen des virtuellen Raums
wo wird es problematisch wo eckig an
alle
spielen beziehungsweise tatsächlich wenn
wir jetzt den Bogen zu spielen schlagen
ja auch unsere Ideen geben also jedes
Spiel hat Regeln und die geben wir uns
ja auch tatsächlich
selber gelernt damit umzugehen wir
lernen zu respektieren wir lernen
Frustration umzugehen also ich glaube
Oma das hast du sehr viel besser
erklären können aber letztendlich alles
Sachen die man letztendlich auch im
Umgang mit einem Meter wär so mit
virtuellen Realitäten einfach hier auch
da um umlegen kann umsetzen kann
übersetzen kann in dem Kontext voll ich
meine dass das Schlimme am Spielen
so gut machen ist dass es eine
geschützte Raum ist deswegen hatten wir
vielleicht eine Realität mehr Probleme
mit dem change aber jetzt nicht ganz so
geschützt ist und im Meter was wenn du
so willst also eigentlich dafür was man
ganz plastisch sieht dann wieder nichts
passieren mach halt ein Mist da drin was
im Metag was passiert bleibt im Meter
wird
theoretisch
aber aber eigentlich müssten wir da
völlig offen dafür sein ja was das
angeht und da der Punkt das ist was ich
gerade gesagt hast mit der Mensch ist
nur Deutsch oder nein du hast mit den
Regeln bist du gekommen ich meine das
ist auch so ein geiles Ding überlegt
euch mal was ein Spiel es hat mir einer
von euch ein Spiel definiert
ist gar nicht so einfach wie definiert
man Spiel
keine Idee
okay es gibt weltweit keine Definition
auf die sich alle gehandelt haben ja ich
habe eine Definition ist nicht von mir
das von Bernhard sweet ich finde die
genial und die bewahrheitet sich immer
nichts ein Spiel der freiwillige Versuch
unnötige Hindernisse zu verwenden
und das stimmt auch bei eurem Hobby das
stimmt im Sport das stimmt in der Musik
das stimmt also hier du ich habe gelernt
du warst Musik gelernt und alles das ist
man fordert sich man hat ein Stück er
hat jetzt probiert man es anders Komplex
sagen zwei wie auch immer in der Musik
bin ich jetzt leider nein aber ähm wir
lieben diese Situation und wenn man so
wieder will ist ist das weder ich sag
mal hätte mal daneben die Brille sitzt
die eben auch alle mal testen können
später
aber der Punkt ist das ist eigentlich
der perfekte Raum wo wir uns voll diesen
diesen Möglichkeiten diesen Bedürfnis
noch mal hingehen können
spielen ist das eine schwere Dinge
leicht machen und leichte Dinge schwer
machen genau und sie sind immer hart
gleich zu Beginn und hatten
okay ich glaube ich würde jetzt
tatsächlich hier noch einen kurzen Katz
setzen würde tatsächlich mal zu meinem
Kollegen hier hinter gucken und ihn
bitten ob er uns mal auf dem Screen
tatsächlich den Trailer wollte indem ich
heute gerne zeigen würde weil und ich
glaube das ist jetzt in der hat schon
ganz wie lange diskutieren klar geworden
dass wenn wir uns mit dem Begriff des
Wohnens auseinandersetzen wir ja
letztlich Leben meinen und aufhalten
also das heißt was heißt denn wohnen was
tun wir denn wenn wir in unseren
Wohnungen in unserem Häusern sind also
da schlafen wir da essen wir da arbeiten
wir da spielen wir da waschen wir uns
den Grundbedürfnissen nach das heißt ich
glaube es ist ganz automatisch dass wir
heute auch uns tatsächlich immer mal
wieder von diesem von diesem wohnen
Begriff
wettbewegen und ich weiß nicht ob das
erste Mal bei dieser Boss passiert 1
Meter Girls da ist tatsächlich der
Trailer und ich würde gerne anfangen mit
dem Film ready Player one ich weiß nicht
kennt jemand den Film ready Player one
ich sehe ein bisschen ein dicken ist
tatsächlich ein Film der auch von Roman
basiert der genauso heißt dass 2011
rausgekommen der Roman dann findet ich
mir jetzt gar nicht sicher spielt im
Jahre 2045 und wir sind tatsächlich über
diesen Film auf die Idee zum heutigen
Format gekommen wir saßen zusammen als
wir hier diese Themenwelt konzipiert
haben und überlegt haben was machen wir
und der greift im Endeffekt ein bisschen
das auf nämlich diese Frage die ich
eingangs gestellt habe was machen wir
eigentlich wenn unsere Lebensumwelt so
leben zu Unwert geworden ist was machen
wir wenn wir nur noch in Slums wohnen
wie es ja in den Mega cities heutzutage
für Millionen von Menschen Realität ist
die Wohnwagen in Asien in dem wir müssen
uns dann übereinander gestapelt ich
glaube sie heißen tatsächlich aus
stables also wirklich übereinander
geschichtete im Wohnwagen
was was machen wir dann wenn diese
Lebensumwelt wirklich so lebensfeindlich
geworden ist und der Film beschreibt
tatsächlich dass es dann eine und ich
würde schon sagen wir haben im Vorfeld
sagen diskutiert ob wir den Begriff der
Flucht reinbringen also die Flucht ins
virtuelle und als ich den Film gesehen
habe ich ich würde es also Flucht
definieren also von dieser wirklich
total lebensfeindlichen Umwelt flüchtet
man sich mit Hilfe einer VR-Brille mit
so einem ganz körperanzug würde ich
jetzt beschreiben tatsächlich in die
Oasis die Oasis wirklich ein virtueller
Raum wo alles passiert da lebe ich da
wohne ich der liebe ich da arbeite ich
da erlebe ich Abenteuer da kann ich
Dinge die ich sonst nicht kann das ist
ja auch so ein bisschen in virtuellen
Realitäten da kann ich Dinge vielleicht
tun die ich im analogen noch nicht kann
genau ich würde jetzt tatsächlich hier
einfach einfach den den Trailer mal
abspielen und dauert zweieinhalb Minuten
dass wir einfach mal so ein bisschen
Eindruck kriegen
bitte lassen
[Musik]
ich bin 2025 geboren
aber ich will lieber in den 80ern
aufgewachsen
sie alle meine Helden
ich lebe jeden Fall lange so heim
2045 die am schnellsten wachsen der
Stadt der Erde was einem aber nicht so
vorkommt wenn man in den Stacks wohnt
man nennt unsere Generation die
verlorenen Millionen
und nicht über die verschwunden werden
man kann nichts mehr hin
neoses
hier habe ich das Gefühl dass ich was
wert bin
und
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich bereit
okay
ja also ganz kurze Einblick tatsächlich
für MICH weiß ich ja wo man ob ich noch
was gehört hat aber tatsächlich für mich
glaube ich das eindrucksvoll was ich in
den letzten Jahren gesehen habe wirklich
zum Thema virtuelle Realität also
allumfassend
absolut immersiv
totalitär im Sinne von wirklich man kann
auch aus seinem Körper rausnehmen man
kriegt mein Körper man hat Fähigkeiten
die man nicht hat
ich würde tatsächlich nach dem ganz
kurzen Einblick einsteigen und noch mal
ein bisschen auf das Thema Wohnen
zurückzukommen oder machen wir es gerne
größer auf und sagen legen Leben im
Sinne von Erfüllung von
Grundbedürfnissen mit wohnen auch im Zug
von im Sinne von Rückzug Sicherheit das
ist meine Burg hinter mir die ich mich
zurückziehen kann ist das Wohnen im
metaverso eine wirkliche Alternative
Jörg als Philosoph
zunächst du meintest das ist sicherlich
der intensivste Firma der thematisiert
ist Mittagessen sicherlich am besten es
gibt noch mehr Tricks ne Magix ist auch
noch so ein Thema wobei der auch noch
mal andere Fragen mit reinkommen aber
ich stimme total zu
worauf ich so aus philosophischer Sicht
gerne hinweisen würde wäre das Problem
der Körperlichkeit
also in diesen virtuellen Realitäten
existieren wir nicht körperlich ja wir
haben eine Szene gesehen ganz kurz wo
diese Autofahrer die Türen zugeklappt
haben und da war kurz eine Szene wo man
gesehen hat das
haben wir wirklich gemacht
sondern die Bewegung
durch aber jetzt kann sich fragen haben
die jetzt wirklich die Autotüre
zugemacht oder war das nur eine
Simulation eine ganz spannende
philosophische Frage ich möchte nur
darauf hinweisen dass man die virtuelle
Realität wie sie hier diese Film
vorgestellt wurde auch im kritischen
Hinsicht als eine Form von Weltflucht
interpretieren kann also eine
Realitätsflucht und virtuelle Realität
wie ich sie gerne aus philosophischer
Sicht verstehen würde darf gerade keine
Realitätsflucht sein so muss eine
realitätserweiterung sein man kann es
drüber schreiben ist es eine
realitätserweiterung oder nicht das sind
gibt es verschiedene Meinungen dazu habe
ich glaube was wir nicht haben sollten
wir eine Realitätsflucht zu haben weil
es in dieser Realität die wir jetzt
gerade physisch körperlich haben weil es
uns da so schlecht geht weil wir beengt
Leben man kann Zukunftsszenarien sich
überlegen dass wir dann eine künstliche
Scheinwelt Fragezeichen uns brauchen in
die wir uns zurückziehen oder flüchten
das würde in meinen Augen diesen sehr
wichtigen Begriff der virtuellen
Realität nicht gerecht werden also da
würde ich dann immer sagen Stopp wo ist
jetzt hier die Scheinwelt was ist jetzt
der Unterschied zwischen Virtualität und
scheinbar und virtuelle Realität sollte
nach meinem Begriffen keine scheinwerden
Zahlen sondern sie sollte eine
Erweiterung unserer Lebenswelt sein in
der wir dienen sind können wir die wir
sonst nicht tun können ohne dass wir uns
dahin flüchten müssen sondern immer im
Sinne Erweiterung das ganze verstehen
soll aber Roman du hast bestimmte andere
Auffassung davon also ich habe ein
bisschen Problem mit der also einmal
finde ich immer das ist auf der einen
Seite schön wenn Filme das aufnehmen
weil der das groß rausbringen ja
natürlich interessant machen auf der
anderen Seite ist das Storytelling die
müssen historisch sein die müssen jetzt
extrem gehen und meistens ist das
zerstörerische extrem immer
unterhaltsamer also schöpferischer
extrem das heißt nicht dass der Mensch
so wird also wenn Du Dir mal die ganzen
Sachen siehst die die erfolgreichsten
langfristigen auch Spiele das sind
schöpferische spiele ja ich meine wir
alle reden jetzt immer übers Meter was
bleiben aber mit der bleibt
aktiv drüber seid nicht mit den heißen
damals das ist
aktivische Sachen ja genau ja also genau
also alle mit diesen ganzen Spiel aber
wie gesagt vom Thema her könnte man
sagen okay wenn du Warcraft
aufzubauen zu machen aber auch second
lifes hält seit langem ja und ist nur
schöpferisch
Minecraft eigentlich das erfolgreichste
Spieler des letzten Jahrzehnts nur
schöpferisch also der Mensch ist viel
viel besser als das was wir im Film und
suggeriert bekommen ist schon mal ein
wichtiger Punkt glaube ich ähm deswegen
sind das immer interessante Einstiege
aber frei leider bringt uns gleich eine
Richtung die die die überhaupt nicht
realistisch ist also nicht mehr Masse
als Massenphänomen das zweite ist das
bestimmter Flucht Flucht ist immer so
ich habe Angst vor etwas ich glaube es
gibt ja du kannst ja auch aus guten
Gründen da reingehen nicht weil du Angst
vor der Realität hast sondern weil du
weißt du kannst das vielleicht nutzen um
mit der Realität was zu verbessern also
auch diese warum die Masse der Menschen
wenn die da reingeht hat es auch lange
nicht zum Flucht zu tun ganz wenige
werden flüchten also sehen finde ich das
aber schwer was ist mit dem mit dem mit
dem anderen zu tun hat ist also du hast
vorhin gesagt mit dem wohnen leben dass
man da so Aktivitäten macht ja dann ist
dort man schläft dort weil wir auch mal
so lang wird's nicht ablaufen können
brauchen wir darüber jetzt nicht reden
wird nie also die Realität ersetzen ist
es irgendwann möglich ich traue den
Menschen alles zu dass er technisch
viele sind
nicht immer nicht so mein Leben sein
möglich sein ich glaube schon ich glaube
der Mensch findet für solche
physikalischen wie auch immer ja ich
meine Frag mal einen von 20 Jahren
spannende Frage das ist der die Frage
nach dem Transhumanismus also ready kurz
weil vielleicht kennt der ein oder
andere von Ihnen dieses Buch das
singularities es gibt also eine
zukunftsspekulation die sagt irgendeinem
jahrhundert im Jahr 2200 2.150 da ist
die technologische Entwicklung so weit
vorangeschritten dass Mensch und
Maschine verschmelzen das praktisch die
Evolution die bisher nur natürlich war
dass sie sich auf technologischer Ebene
weiterführen und das Maschinen würden
sich auch bewusst sein entwickeln dass
wir Videos gesagt hast unser Gehirn
unser Geist als wir den uploadeen können
die glaubt bei uns macht es nun zum
Körper loslösen können letztendlich ist
die Frage immer die wie lange brauchen
wir noch unseren Körper
für mich trotzdem nochmal zurück zu der
Frage mit wohnen
/ leben weil und du hast einen ganzen
ganz guten Begriff für mich reingeht ich
habe es mir tatsächlich auch auf meine
Karte der körperliche greift und ich
bemühe trotzdem noch mal den Begriff der
Flucht auch wenn ich weiß ihr beide mögt
das nicht so gerne aber trotz alledem
wenn es irgendwann so lebensfeindlich
wird dass ich sage das ist ein Ort an
dem möchte ich mich eigentlich nicht
aufhalten also wenn ich jetzt nach Hause
gehe eine schöne Wohnung ich habe
welches Wohnzimmer sie ihr alle
wahrscheinlich auch ein schönes
gemütliches Wetter können wir uns alle
heute abend einkuscheln mehr haben
Wasserhahn können wir auch machen kommt
aber das Wasser raus das heißt wenn ich
diese diese Umstände in der Realität im
analogen Raum nicht mehr wiederfinde
und jetzt hast du diesen Begriff der
Körperlichkeit eingebracht
ist es trotzdem möglich ist zumindestens
eine Art von Körperlichkeit in einem
virtuelle Realität zu transportieren
kann ich mich da tatsächlich so
sicher so gemütlich so kuschelig fühlen
ohne dass ich gleich diesen für mich
trotzdem noch sehr krassen Schritt hat
zu sagen okay ich uploade mich jetzt ist
sie sehen im Hintergrund er tatsächlich
noch im zweiten Trailer eine Serie da
ist genau das Thema also dieses uploaden
vom Geist wenn ich den Schritt nicht
gehe kann ich einen Körperlichkeit
Grundbedürfnisse des Menschseins was wir
ja ganz viel in unserem Zuhause in
unserem Räumen tun kann ich das
transportieren kann ich das mitnehmen
und erleben Oma
also erstens mal rein technologisch mit
einiges mehr also es gibt jetzt schon
Sachen wo du in der virtuellen Welt
Dinge anfassen kannst und du spürst
wirst ein ob du die fühlst ja oder nicht
durch irgendeinen Force Feedback Motor
sondern weil die das machen können sogar
Autogramme kannst Du inzwischen anfassen
und spüren also das ist eine technische
Frage die lösbar ist der andere Punkt
ist mit dem Leben ich meine wir haben
heute virtuelle Realität was passiert
bei mir im Kopf ja und das schöne
Beispiel ist also ich habe sie vorhin
gesagt wir arbeiten im Ding drin du
fängst irgendwann an eine gewisse
emotionale Verbindung zu diesem
virtuellen Raum zu schaffen du weißt
wenn ich in dem Raum bin können wir nur
so das Thema wenn ich in dem Raum bin
kann man das Thema sollen wir das
und ich habe es dir vorhin erzählt ich
habe das mal ich habe mal die virtuelle
eigentlich mehr aus Experiment Freude
aber im ICE angesetzt weil ich wissen
wollte wie meine Mitmenschen reagieren
und also der Punkt ist du bist in diesem
ICE drin und du setzt ein dein Ding auf
und bist plötzlich in deinem Büro und du
fängst an diese Emotionen du findest
diese Gewohnheit diese du fühlst dich
vielleicht doch ein bisschen sicher wie
auch immer ja wenn du weißt wie alles
läuft wo was ist die Dinge haben wir
auch eine noch eine gewisse
Geräuschkulisse ja das nicht sofort also
das Gehirn schließt ja so Lücken
und und von daher also rein dieses sagen
wir mal diese Geborgenheit die du
vielleicht weil ich bei mir im Büro
nicht physisch geworden fühle diese
virtuelle Brille Aufsätze dadurch diese
Geborgenheit mit reinnehmen und wenn ich
dann in einem Raum mit einem Kontext wo
ich mich nicht so geborgen fühle diese
Brille aufsetzen kannst gut sein dass
sie mir einfach mich morgen dazu führen
weil
also von daher glaube ich schon dass du
das das gewissen Teil jetzt schon
erleben kannst was dieses
Problem geworden ist ich würde einen
haben ich stimme dir eigentlich zu ich
würde jetzt so formulieren wir können
einiges virtualisieren aber eben noch
lange nicht alles also wir können sehr
gut Arbeitsprozesse virtualisieren so
wie du es beschrieben hast dass ich mit
Hilfe dieser Brille verschiedene
Desktops vor mir habe und nicht mehr
angewiesen bin auf diese blöden
physikalischen Objekte die mir da mein
Schreibtisch letztendlich versperren der
sich überall Arbeitsplätze habe und auch
wirklich arbeiten kann weil das was ich
dann machen ICE Videos beschrieben hast
das bringt mir am Ende auch das Geld
aufs Konto und zwar vielleicht mehr als
wenn ich es auf meinem besch physischen
Schreibtisch tätigen manche Dinge können
wir virtualisieren durch solche
Arbeitsräume aber eben lange nicht alles
das heißt viele Bereiche unserer
Realität eben noch stärker den Körper
gebunden sind die können wir in meinen
Augen nicht virtualisieren oder nur sehr
begrenzt das heißt aus meiner
philosophischen Perspektive würde ich
immer kritisch fragen was lässt sich
virtualisieren und was lässt sich nicht
virtualisieren häufig sind eben solche
Fiktionen so verfasst dass sie in
totalitären Anspruch haben und behaupten
wir können alles virtualisieren und da
würden dann in meinen Augen die Grenzen
des Möglichen etwas überschritten
konkrete Frage ich kuschel mich ja ein
warmes Federbett schönes Kopfkissen und
in echt liege ich auf dem Holzbrett
ein Auge geht es nicht also
transportiert ich glaube tatsächlich
technisch wahrscheinlich irgendwann
möglich dass ich wirklich auch am
Holzbrett liegen und trotzdem das Gefühl
habe du kannst das Gehirn so gut
täuschen ich meine wenn jeder von uns
kennt optische Täuschungen das sind so
einfache Dinge und mit der Technologie
mit anderen ich sage nicht das ist gut
ich sage alles gut ich kann dafür sorgen
denkt super Wasserbett wenn ich Durst
habe noch so viele virtuelle simulierte
Quellen im Metaversum anzapfen ich werde
verdursten also manche Dinge kann ich
einfach nicht virtualisieren ich muss
natürlich ich muss in dieser physischen
Welt irgendwie dann Infusion bekommen
die mir dann simulieren dass ich jetzt
was trinke aber da bin ich dann wieder
angewiesen auf diese physische also wie
gesagt das ist jetzt kommen wir
zumindest historische so ein bisschen ja
aber ich kann auch das nicht ich kann es
nicht man kann dafür sorgen dass Leute
verdursten und kein Durst spüren gut
also das ist also blöd gesagt ja aber
das ist das schon krass was möglich ist
wenn du wenn du weiter durch gewisse
Kontexte an dem Gehirn und Streiche
spielen kannst also ich habe tatsächlich
auch ins gute übrigens es geht auch
super ins gute das machen ja
ein bisschen im Kopf gehabt als ich
gefragt habe nur so diese diese Sachen
die man ja daheim weiß bei sich tut ne
ganz alltägliche Dinge die stehende
Küche und brutzeln ja längere Schnitzel
das riecht das äh dann da liegt bestimmt
der Geruch und ich schaffe ich das
sozusagen zu virtualisieren obwohl ich
mir einfach irgendeine gezüchtete
Materie aus dem Labor gerade brutzel
aber trotzdem kriege ich eine Infusion
und hat das Gefühl ich trinke jetzt
einen mehr los von
2008 aus dem eichenerfassung und bin
total happy lustig ich würde halt gerne
in der Show inzwischen Simulation
perfekter Simulation oder auch Illusion
wirklich ein virtuelle Realität also da
unterscheiden das was du sehr triffst
beschrieben hast sind
Illusionen Simulationen die an uns
eingeht das ist für mich aus
philosophischer Sicht nicht der voll
sind und diese engere sind von
virtueller Realität nicht vom Sinn wir
reden von das was einer stimmt der
Mensch kann das Material empfinden aber
er wäre letztendlich getäuscht also er
wäre
[Musik]
praktisch dringer stärker zu fassen von
der Illusion abgrenzen dafür aber auch
reduzieren auf nur wenige Bereiche der
Anwendung also das was du geschrieben
hast diese Arbeit Setting ist für mich
ein perfektes Beispiel für wirkliche
Realität virtuelle Realität weil du alle
Zwecke damit realisiert hast die du
sollst am Schreibtisch machen
du kannst auch also wir hocken da alle
am Tisch jeder hat seine Avatar ja so an
dieser Avatar die sind gut gemacht also
die die sehen ich sehe auch ich dachte
der Augenkontakt ist realistisch die
Armbewegung sind realistisch wenn der
mir die Zunge rausschneiden wenn der
gehen sehe ich das nicht also auch diese
haben natürlich nicht die real,-
[Musik]
das funktioniert aber natürlich hast du
da auch diese
und wahrscheinlich finden die auch
Tricks raus dass die irgendwie
eigentlich nur die ganze Zeit aufs Meer
rausgucken und ich glaube die gucken
mich an keine Ahnung
das gar nicht schlimm also ich würde ich
würde einfach ich habe so Probleme aus
philosophischer Sicht auch ethischer
Sicht dann letztendlich tut
die Inklusion eingespeist werden weil
dann werden wir manchmal hier war dann
sind wir nicht mehr autonomen man kann
uns verschiedene Dinge einschmeißen die
ich möchte wirklich etwas erreichen ich
möchte wirklich trinken und nicht nur
irgendwelche Reize eingespeist bekommen
die mir die Illusion verschaffen dass
ich jetzt nicht mehr durstig werde okay
völligator völligator aber der Zug ist
abgefallen schon eine Realität seit
langem dass wir nicht mal die das wird
autonomen unterwegs oder so ich meine
Leute nehmen es ist schöne Beispiel mit
irgendwie
ich meine das ist jetzt das ist nur der
ganz kleine Punkt davon ja aber das
zeigt einfach wir ticken wenn du peps
wie ein Cola trinkst findest Du Pech in
der Regel immer besser siehst du die
Aufschrift findest du Cola immer besser
also ist jetzt ein ganz blödes Beispiel
das sieht man wie wir durch eine gewisse
im ja ja
durch durch eine gewisse Konditionierung
dein Geschmack sind
wieder zu dass wir in dieser phys
isch Gebet nicht auch permanent
Einflüssen unterliegen und Manipulation
das ist auch keine Argument für das
virtuelle also das sehe ich auch aber
völlig da Chor als auch da brauchen wir
politische Sicht auf psychologische
Einflussnahme wir sind ständig solchen
ausgesetzt ethische sondern völlig
richtig okay also
meine letzte Frage tatsächlich ist weil
ich ja trotzdem auch in der Konzeption
in dieses Abends und auch wie ich jetzt
trotzdem diesen immer diesen Kopf was
ist wenn wir wenn wir müssen als wenn
wir keine Wahl mehr haben da wäre jetzt
vor allem tatsächlich an die Jörg die
Frage wir haben es vorher schon
angeteasert als wir angefangen haben zu
reden dass er virtuelle Realität auch
ruhig wirklich was Neues ist und wir
hatten mit Geld und Zeit und der Mensch
hat schon immer Dingen Bedeutung
verdienen die Sie per sie nicht aus der
Natur aus sich heraus haben
wir haben davon gesprochen dass das
zuzahlen war mal was ganz ganz
gefährlich ist da fliegen einem die
Augen raus und früher hatten auch darauf
geachtet dass Frauen und Kinder nicht so
viel lesen weil da wird man hysterisch
von und gerade bei den Frauen musste
immer aufpassen wenn ich zu viel Bücher
lesen dann werden die ganz komisch und
so na das was du gesagt hast Roman wie
war
was passiert ist nachdem man geboren ist
ne
bleiben wir trotzdem bei dieser trotzdem
sehr unsexy Variante wir müssen
irgendwann und
unsere Kinder wachsen da vielleicht
nicht mehr auf unsere
Uhren was macht das mit dem Menschen und
dann kommt für mich wirklich dieser
Punkt wir haben uns angesprochen dieser
Doppelung also nicht weil Bob Leben
der Mensch ich habe ihn jetzt gerade so
zweigeteilten Menschen vor mir was macht
es mit dem Menschen wenn wir in zwei
Welten lebt und die auch wenn wir davon
ausgehen es gibt irgendwann eine
perfekte Simulation es gibt den
perfekten schreien von der Realität
nicht mehr zu unterscheiden aber trotz
alledem leben wir dann in zwei Welten
auch zu unterschiedlichen Prozentanteil
was macht es mit der Menschheit was
macht das vielleicht mit unserem
wird der Mensch anders eine neue Form
von Evolution
das wird mit der Menschheit passieren
und weiß ich nicht ich glaube das wird
in Rollen ist nicht so ein Problem
ehrlich gesagt weil ich glaube es wird
der Mensch ist gar nicht fähig dazu zwei
komplett verschiedene Leben zu führen
ich glaube da würde vorher ausbrennen
wie auch immer und auch wenn du jetzt
zum Beispiel Leute nimmst du mal das
Beispiel zu nehmen die komplett in einer
Spielewelt Leben
das sind ja meistens gesagt sie bekommt
so viel Zeit da drin da fängt auch an
diese Spielewelt ich sage übrigens
die anfangen ihren Freundeskreis damit
zu verbinden dass die vielleicht Freunde
in der Realität aus dem Spiel haben
umgekehrt dass sie Freunde in Realität
mit dabei nehmen dass sie
gewisses dass wir das schöne Beispiel
für Second Life Verletzung unglaublich
viele Leute im Job da drin und sich
erarbeitet haben und dort drin und dann
halt die digitale Währung verdient und
dann reale umtauschen also es
verschmelzt automatisch und was was was
ich glaube der Mensch kann es gar nicht
anders trennen und wie kann ich machen
und wie gesagt er würde ausbrennen und
dadurch ein bisschen einfacher weil du
machst das eine der einfällt bedingt die
anderen umgekehrt
also mittlerweile wird der Mensch sich
weiter klappen jeder jeder Kontext jede
Veränderung jede neue Technologie
verändern uns es gab mal irgendwie so
eine Definition ich fand ich super von
Digitalisierung die Digitalisierung ist
für die für also in dem Kontext weil sie
nichts anderes als die veränderte
veränderte menschliche Verhaltensweise
in einer jetzt
technologiebuffetikerin Welt in sowas
und ich fand das handelt die Ebene auf
den Menschen gegeben und hat gar nicht
gezeigt wie er sich das alles zu nutze
macht und anpasst
ja genau also ich bin da sehr positiv
unterwegs was das angeht also ich glaube
die Frage ob stellt sich nicht aber
drüber nachgedacht wird irgendeiner
bauen wird irgendwann das missbrauchen
ausprobieren die gehen voran oder die
Birds die anderen kommt nach wenn es ein
bisschen besser ist
ich glaube der Mensch ist vom Grund auf
positiv
merkt man übrigens auch also nur mal so
kurz also auch wenn sich das immer nicht
so anhört wir haben weltweit immer
weniger kriege immer weniger Tote als
die Vergangenheit ja medial kommt es
immer näher an uns aber wir haben immer
weniger hungertote wir haben also nur
mal so ja also der Mensch das sind
Fakten also
genau das ist der Mensch in dem Fall
natürlich
großen Körper große Chaos verhindern
können großen Zusammenbruch irgendwann
aber von daher diese beiden Fakten
zusammen sehe ich als sehr positiv
ich glaube dann würde ich glaube ich mit
diesem Optimismus zumindestens den
offiziellen Teil des Abends beenden wir
hatten es vorher schon angesprochen
Roman hat tatsächlich eine VR Brille
dabei also wer jetzt gerne mal
ausprobieren möchte dass sie mal
aufsetzen möchte mein Gefühl dafür
kriegen möchte ist herzlich eingeladen
der ansonsten irgendwie noch eine Frage
hat an unsere zwei Experten ist
sicherlich noch ein paar Minuten hier
und ja wer sich sonst noch gerne auch in
Zweiergruppen Dreiergruppen austauscht
seien Sie herzlich willkommen ansonsten
sage ich vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse
gut nach Hause weg und schönen Abend und
wir sehen uns bald hoffentlich in der
analogen Welt vielleicht irgendwann in
der virtuellen vielen Dank danke fürs
mitmachen
[Applaus]